an American tourist who was held captive
in war-ravaged Syria for two months is
finally free
Sam Goodwin of st. Louis was released
following secret negotiations involving
a member of the Lebanese military CBS
News State Department reporter Christina
Ruffini has the latest on the man who
had been on a journey across the globe
his mission was simple Sam Goodwin would
not return home until he'd visited every
country in the world and there were
apparently no exceptions
not even Syria where the bloody
seemingly intractable Civil War has
killed an estimated half a million
people in the last eight years
unable to get an official visa the 30
year old entered the country through a
Kurdish controlled checkpoint in the
northeast reportedly wandered the
streets without a guide and was
eventually picked up by Syrian
government forces he was convicted of
illegal entry and spent more than two
months in custody it puts a lot of
things into perspective that's probably
the biggest thing that that I learned
and it really makes you appreciate
everything that you have here Goodwin
who grew up in st. Louis has been an
avid traveler since college in 2012 he
told his campus TV station a trip to
Africa had changed his perspective on
life coming off an experience like that
you really realize that you're what you
consider problems are really maybe not
as severe as you may think they are good
ones detention inside Syria was not
widely known his surprise release
yesterday was secured with the help of a
Lebanese general who negotiated with the
Syrian government on behalf of his
family Goodwin was reunited with his
parents overseas we are forever indebted
to Lebanese general Abbas Ibrahim and to
all others who helped secure the release
of our son they said in a statement the
62 days Goodwin spent in custody may
seem like a long time but it's actually
relatively short for these kinds of
detentions which can drag on for years
everyone we spoke to yesterday both
inside
outside the government said they were
thrilled by the outcome Dana sources
tell CBS News no ransom was paid for his
release Christina thank you